on va commencer par licorne nikon qui me
regardait beaucoup sur france 4
au début sur des mythes et tu m'as
appris à mais complètement
bah non c'est pas là ça va ma chérie
t'inquiète pas alors dis mon compte et
non parce que voilà et pour tes contre
aussi rénale qu'il était contre moi la
télé actuellement oui d'accord mais
celle donc tu voudrais quoi que je fasse
quoi du flipper tout sauf de la télé
pour éviter de voir ta tête d'accor
attendait et aux non mais on a demandé à
licorne devenir s'est elle dit ce
qu'elle pense voilà donc là là tu viens
cauchemar non j'ai pas un cauchemar je
suis super content de pouvoir le dire
face à face et bah ça fait plaisir je
suis quelqu'un j'aime bien être franc
exactement j'aime bien montrer justement
ce que j'ai à dire est ce que tu veux
nombreux tweets sur moi je l'aurais
chaque fois beaucoup
alors dis nous ce qui te dérange et à
petit nous pourquoi tu es contre moi à
la nar dix mois zada parce que je trouve
que les choses ont beaucoup changé
depuis le début des émissions
donc comme je disais je regardais tpm
fait depuis le début et au fur et à
mesure du temps ce qui les passe à des
visites c'est pas ça c'est 8 parce que
bon la chambre et changer de nom sur de
plus en plus moi je te tutoie pas ce que
tu est de la même génération que moi
mais tu vous regardez sur france 4 aussi
ouais c'est ça mais même au niveau de
l'ambiance générale des chroniqueurs
il ya un malaise quoi mais alors on
revient un malaise complet mais
maintenant tu dis tu dis ce que tu mens
est ce que tu penses pas c'est plutôt
les gens qui ont changé par rapport à
nous parce que serena en mission a eu un
énorme succès et c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup plus de gens qui se sont
intéressés à l'émission et qu'on fait
peut-être que chaque chose qui se
passait dans l'émission devenait un
énorme buzz alors le buzz moi déjà je
suis un peu contre le faux buzz
oui mais dont l'effet que nous mais les
nous tu vois ya beaucoup de journalistes
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle les pus
tacle c'est parce qu'ils savent que
voilà ça fait énormément paris pour
faire des articles contre nous c'est
vrai qu'ils font que forcément
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois
qu'on fait quelque chose c'est beaucoup
plus scrutés que lorsqu'on était sur
france 4 on faisait du bois cent
cinquante mille téléspectateurs c'est un
peu normal encore cherche tout ça on
l'obtient non mais non on cherche pas
c'est vrai que moi je trouve quand même
que petit à petit au niveau de ton
comportement haut niveau sa façon d'être
des gros mots
ta façon
et nous on prend plus fameux jeu
génération que ces masses raquette
dérange pas tout tout tout les rien pour
marc monfray rahmane voilà tout ça mais
moi je comprends rien quoi c'est bien
qu'elle le dise dommage avec délégués
qui voulait prendre la parole oui bah
ils vont sortir le bon sens à tous moi
je trouve ça très bien déjà je voudrais
vous remercier d'être venu et et je loue
votre courage parce que ça change de
tous les acteurs qui interviennent
actuellement sur twitter et qui peuvent
balancer des insultes donc je vous
remercie d'être d'être là face à nous
justement ce que vous dites c'est la
différence par rapport à la première moi
je la regarde donc depuis 2010 depuis la
première et moi au contraire je vois un
fil conducteur par rapport à la première
édition et je trouve que cyril est le
même
je vais même vous dire mieux l'émission
en fait je pense que c'est ce qui gêne
l'émission est devenue populaire et moi
populaire n'est pas un gros mot
contraire c'est un mot que j'affectionne
et et c'est ce que disait cyril pour
avoir dont on bossait dans la
communication et pour connaître des
journalistes qui bossent surtout en
ligne et nous le disent quand on est en
ligne
il faut faire des il faut faire du clic
parce que c'est ça qui nous fait ramener
de l'argent et quand on fait un article
sur hanouna comme on fait un article sur
tp mp avec un avec un titre plus ta
clique ont fait de l'oseille et c'est ce
qu'on nous donne c'est dingue et c'est
dingue mais malheureusement cela c'est
ça qu'on voit que tu m'as donne
malheureusement scénario alors si vous
regardez des articles généralement c'est
un micro événement vraiment un micro
événement et qu'ils enfants message il
accole vous rappelle un truc qui comme
moyen un journaliste qui m'a dit
franchement tous les jours et viser des
artistes des articles sur moi cyril
hanouna au fond du gouffre aussi la
ruine et cyril hanouna n'a plus d'amis
je vis mes produits ça hennit moi je te
dis la vérité
dès que voilà je fais c'est juste pour
faire du clic parce que voilà dès qu'on
met ton nom avec un truc négatif à côté
ça ça ça cartonne
et le mec me l'a dit franchement je dis
bah écoute tu sais quoi continue alors
si tu peux faire ton business là dessus
moi la limite ça me dérange pas voilà
fait louable mais là on parle de
business on parle de pika qui n'assure
de tout ça mais moi c'est pas ça le le
suspect principal
2 pourquoi je t'aime pas voici en fait
c'est très pratique pourquoi pas ta
gueule quoi non mais alors ouais alors
oui licorne vase clos parce que voilà
c'est tous et toutes ces petites choses
qui se sont greffés suis en mesure du
temps ta façon d'être
tes rires de yens mais deviennent voilà
mais c'est sûr jouer ses droits réels
c'est pas vrai métier que j'ai toujours
été quelqu'un il faut que ça il ya quand
même une part de vérité
et si c'est trop sûr jouer les gens ils
se détournent pourquoi il ya moins
d'audience aujourd'hui gênant yao doh
toujours toutes les émissions et presque
deux millions on est amis en trois oui
mais oui mes amis ont trois matches et
ris parce que les jeux voices est à 10
millions us soit 3 millions ma chérie
mais ça demande un peu non mais tout me
rabaisser bon bah on avait toujours
souhaité et voilà que je leur dis là moi
de mon dos à télé mais en termes de
pourcentage on fait toujours les mêmes
aux audiences depuis maintenant hausse
et on garde les mêmes audiences depuis
sept ans tu vois donc c'est vrai que
c'est un exploit voilà après toi toi tu
nous a délaissé j'espère que tu
reviendras nous voir si tu veux je pense
personnellement je vais délaisser tmp
d'accord sincèrement m'étais bien tu
l'as eu 2 ap
je vois ta tête je peux plus et quand
c'est castaldi tu regarde jamais jamais
nous affirme à ses yeux dit je suis ça
normal matt evans avant et balances ton
post mais alors balance pas mal à garder
ou pas christine je vous adore avancé
away sincèrement tu veux que je remette
dans tpm
j'adore j'adore balance au poste gentil
je les regardais depuis le tout premier
numéro tu vois franchement je trouve
c'est messi c'est bien ma gueule dans
boy de balances ton bonhomme justement
[Rires]
mais parler d'excès mois est là parce
que pour moi j'ai regardé à l'époque
dechavanne oisienne ou mardi ça me
rappelle énormément tout en subissant
que j'adorais les fight entre les pour
les deux ça c'est très clair a libéré
les les rats j'adore ces exercices mais
tu fais sur l'ip lait ah oui ah oui
j'adore mais le pourrai faudrait un peu
plus quoi on avait des chroniqueurs j'en
ai mis qu'un et pour les balances ton
post sincèrement vu que moi je t'aime
pas en tant que personnage d'insurgés
mère qui regardent l'émission quand même
sélection pour les chroniqueurs d'accord
jimmy pour christine alors justement bas
clavier monde christine toi tu es pour
bon c'est normal d'être tous bords oui
elle à moi déjà je voudrais bien inviter
licorne sous effectivement la
responsabilité de serre et à le suivre
quand même une petite journée juste ont
coulé le thurgovien tu veux qu'elle
meure ou non c'est non non non
intéressant de voir à quel point il est
exactement le même
avant et après le générique et ça fait
partie des raisons pour lesquelles les
rires du gène vous savez jamais rien
deviennent ses jumeaux c'est une semaine
avec moi ouais ouais malicorne pourquoi
est-ce que je suis là c'est justement
malicorne
c'est d'abord parce que j'aime son
personnage parce qu'il est généreux
alors bien sûr j'aurais pu aller sur
d'autres émissions avant mais j'ai aimé
sa générosité jamais je connais beaucoup
de patrons de chaînes de présentateurs
télé d'animateur de journalisme jamais
je n'ai vu quelqu'un jeudi avant même de
travailler avec lui
jamais je n'ai vu quelqu'un d'aussi
généreux avec son public a même quand
les juniors
[Applaudissements]
c'était comme s'il n'est pas là est ce
utile aux chauffeurs de salle non non
vous n'êtes pas non mais par exemple
quand la lumière s'éteint et parle au
public on n'est plus là il reste à
parler avec eux quand il ya la publie
par le public quand il ya des personnes
en difficulté il va les aider quand les
caméras sont éteintes il va dans les
hôpitaux voir les enfants c'est ça qui
me plaît chez ce bonhomme que beaucoup
ne comprennent pas mais c'est ce qui me
plaît chez lui et c'est la seule raison
pour laquelle je suis là et que je le
supporte
alors je donne la parole aussi à clément
alors que les mots toi aussi voilà ta
italie j'ai commencé à regarder comme
tout le monde au début tu as pas compris
phénomène je n'ai pas le souvenir qu'il
m'est fait marrer une seule fois je n'ai
jamais accroché au personnage je trouve
ça bien qu'il invite des gens qui ne
l'aiment pas si ça pouvait lui permettre
de se remettre en question alors à côte
nous tous tu as fait à 20 ans tu habites
en bretagne féminité en négociation
digitalisation relation client ndrc
c'est ça c'est ça alors dit nous et
perdre qu'on va donner à part bien sûr
aux autres alors moi du coup bah j'ai
commencé à regarder donc tpm tu es quand
ça commence à faire le buzz
bien sûr et tout le monde disait que
c'était bien donc j'ai commencé à
regarder j'en ai regardé un j'ai eu du
mal
2-3 j'ai arrêté je crois tu t'es tu as
donc ça fait une tentative de suicide du
mouv là par exemple
ouais juste d'aucune tu n'aimes pas sa
gelée bien entendu je te tutoie parce
qu'on a presque le même agent j'ai dit
tu n'aimes pas j'ai bien concret sauf
que la question c'est êtes-vous pour ou
contre cyril à demain la télévision
parce que tu n'aimes pas est ce que tu
es contre cyril hanouna la télévision
aujourd'hui on a plus de 300 chaînes à
la télévision on à youtube
on a plein d'autres plateformes on peut
regarder des émissions en replay si tu
n'aimes pas j'aurais pu dire bah le
regarde pas il ya plein de choses que tu
peux regarder et et moi au contraire
c'est ça que c'est c'est ce qu'a défendu
aussi cyril à la télévision c'est on va
parler de traits mission télé sans
forcément mettre m le viseur sur nous et
moi aussi pourquoi je dis que cyril
hanouna pour moi et d'utilité publique
cyril hanouna sans touche pas à mon
poste c'est ce que des gens auraient
compris ce qu'est une part d'audience ce
qu'est la ménagère
parce que sur certaines cibles ce que
les coûts de production il ya
aujourd'hui six raids mais nos amis dans
les coulisses de la télévision alors que
l'on était complètement exclu de ça ça
c'est la première des choses
la deuxième des choses c'est pour ça que
je dis souvent que je le compare 1 2
vannes ou 1 de la rue pour moi il a
marqué la télévision française faire de
la faire du direct aujourd'hui à la
télévision malheureusement c'est devenu
très très rare je crois que danse avec
les stars y seront en différé quotidien
c'est la même annonce est le seul
aujourd'hui qui fait du direct et c'est
sa grande force il de maîtrise
c'est tellement savoir ce qui peut
basculer d'une partie data comme la
semaine dernière sur tes pmp et 30
minutes après finir avec les membres du
gouvernement avec lui pour donner la
parole en français je trouve que c'est
sa grande force c'est pour ça que moi je
partirai lannoy la terreur bah ouais je
sens qu'on va finir très tard je sens
très mal
il est chiant lebrija alors oui m'ont
dit nous donc on dis nous ce que tu
ressens dit nous pourquoi tu es contre
non je crois c'est le personnage
d'accord le fait du mil et écroué en
choeur tout le temps après non c'est une
humiliation même c'est vicieux et
certains certainement quand tu parles du
chocolat au lait sma le chocolat
l'assimiler au tas d'items pas de
chocolat vraiment sérieuse ou l'art pas
de raid en attaque et une nuits pas trop
dedans chevaux tu prennes chocolat ils
ont pris une tôle après une fois non
alors je vais te dire la vérité dans
plusieurs fois oui moi parce que moi
c'est en fait ils le savent ça me
dérange pas du tout en fait de prendre
des trucs sur ailleurs je me les mets
souvent moi-même commode poitiers je
fais le truc défi suisse tout ça donc en
fait moi de prendre des trucs sauriol ça
ça me dérange pas du tout et voilà après
c'est vrai qu'on est parti sur cette
base du chocolat mais voilà se sécher
après voilà c'est c'est devenu un
running gag mais aussi voilà je ne
rechigne pas mais des trucs sur la
gueule à être salis tout ça c'est vrai
que moi ils savent que je m'en fous donc
il essaie de se venger ou autrement
apparemment ils préparent une vengeance
voilà pour la fin de la saison mais je
ne sais pas ce que c'est mais en tout
cas j'aimerais qu'on est bon on écoute
aussi loïc loïc tu viens du 93 tôt si tu
es contre oui je suis contraint la
personne n'en soit pas aussi les sujets
que vous abordez sûr en fait il ya
beaucoup de sujets qui sont sexistes qui
sont aussi homophobes qu'on a dit a qui
sont fait polémique sur la tp mp et ça
ça vient par vous parce que vous avez le
choix des sujets vous avez le choix des
interlocuteurs que vous
que vous faites parler en fait comme
après ces quelques noms de polémique
mais de leurs mots qui parlent sans même
réfléchir ça je trouve ça énorme pour un
chroniqueur sachant que parfois il est
concerné il raconte quand même aussi de
pas mal de merde par exemple sur les
amourettes ça où il parlait mais on ya
toujours deux contradicteurs ont tu vois
c'est ça le truc tu as loïc c'est le
débat c'est que mathieu quand il dit une
bêtise il ya souvent un contradicteur
qui vous dit une bêtise
surtout ce ryan a qu'à moi avant par
exemple j'ai défendu maintes et maintes
fois à dacca - tu trouves kapadia pas de
contrepoids merci enfin il peut avoir
des contrepoids mais justement je trouve
que le problème c'est que pourquoi on
est forcé de me montrer ça à la télé
devant des personnes qui vont peut-être
reproduire ça par exemple pour le
canular homophobe je trouve que c'est
scandaleux ce que ça a été fait que des
personnes ont vu ça que des personnes
peut-être que l'on peut être reproduite
et je ne sais pas et après ça a été
quand même cette fois par le csa s'était
emporté 25 mille fois heureusement mais
je trouve ça quand même grave pour une
émission qui veut qu il vous répondra
moi j'aime ce cas les régalades une
seule est ce que les régalades qui sont
faites par tpm paix peuvent être aussi
reproduite par le téléspectateur
bah oui alors qu'il veut répondre à qui
qui veut répondre à allauch icoa clément
ric après après les deux eric d'accord
eric non mais d'abord je trouve que
c'est la nonna a trouvé un moyen très
subtil d'obliger les gens qui n'aiment
pas regarder quand même l'émission en
vous invitant dans les panneaux je
trouve ça joli
[Applaudissements]
c'est très courageux de leur part
devenir quoi que
bravo devenir c'est magnifique de
pouvoir le dire en sage c'est génial je
vous pose une simple question il ya un
an et quelques il aurait été aberrant de
penser que des ministres viendraient sur
le plateau un plateau d'hanouna pour
discuter avec lui et de discuter avec
lui et avec nous des grands problèmes
nationaux
il ya un an et quelques il aurait pas
aberrant de prétendre que cyril hanouna
phase revenir vers la politique une
classe d'âge ils ont les 16-35 ans qui
sont étaient détachés qui sont étaient
éloignés c'est pourtant ce qui s'est
passé donc moi je trouve que de ce
simple fait cyril hanouna à sa place à
la télévision puisqu'il a apporté
quelque chose qui n'existait pas il a
comblé une lacune c'est que la plupart
des jeunes la télévision ne les concerne
plus la politique ne les concerne plus
et alors la politique à la télévision ça
les concerne encore moins et on a
observé ce phénomène massif semaine
après semaine sur ce plateau
donc je comprends touche pas à mon poste
c'est la déconnade vous êtes moins
sensibles à ça mais balances ton post il
me semble qui a prouvé son utilité
jusqu'à prendre un conscrit liquor dit
entièrement hanouna faut prendre en
entier on peut pas le découper en
tranches angélina peut très bien être
alors je suis allé à l'arrière-plan
faire toutes ces idées comme tu dis eric
parce que moi je t'adore et quelque part
donner l'opportunité à quelqu'un comme
jean y mc elle avoue voix représentées
alors vie mais qu'est ce qu'en pensent
les mais question pour moi je veux rien
présenté du tout
mais là elle donne son idée à la raison
questions réponses sur les polémiques à
loïc voilà parce que je vous m'en rends
compte en fait sans insulter les autres
chroniqueurs autour de la table je
contacte tous les jours de la france du
quotidien en fait celle un peu aussi
j'aime bien aller un peu plus au contact
mais du bon bah non alors oui laurence
et moi allez je t'en prie dans les vases
il part dans ce canal et ses bons
laurence merci donc je suis vraiment
visites à domicile et je vois des gens
qui me reconnaissent mais un gros comme
ça au travers devant disant vous êtes le
médecin de chez hanouna et lorsqu'on
parle de l'aide de l'émission ce qu'ils
disent systématiquement c'est qu'en fin
de journée après une journée de travail
difficile dans un contexte particulier
on a une chaîne d'information continue a
que des mauvaises nouvelles
on est content en fin de journée de
suite et l'esprit et de rigoler et
souvent et des français pour qui le seul
moyen de distraction c'est la télévision
et sont contents d'avoir cette chose-là
qui a parfois elles n'auront pas
paraître s'évader ils partent pas en
vacances
ils sont parfois seuls ils ont du mal à
se déplacer et j'ai même vu une personne
qui ne se déplace jamais de la journée
du matin au soir elle est coincée dans
son lit médicalisé elle se lève une
seule fois c'est à 18h36 pour gagner
touche pas à mon poste est véridique il
m'a dit je me lève de mon fauteuil et je
vais regarder et je me détends et je
m'évade est un outil extraordinaire pour
les français c'est la télécommande
si vous ne voulez pas regarder il suffit
de zapper malek l'a très bien dit à un
panel incroyable de chaîne et il y à
aussi en ce moment une forme de mépris
des élites qui sont on va le dire un peu
jalouse en disant mais touche pas à mon
poste
le monde l'a dit qu'est ce que tu fais
là bas qu'est ce que tu as été faits
relatés médecin n'a pas de temps à
perdre moi je me dis que si certains
français le regarde il faut pas les
mépriser passe quand vous méprisant vous
sert il on méprise le million le million
et demi où les deux millions de
personnes qui regardent quotidiennement
donc fort un peu de recul on vit une
période un peu compliquée
un peu d'humour un peu de détente ça
fait de mal à personne licorne qu'est ce
que tu dis ah ça moi je dis l'humour je
suis d'accord la détente chez l'accord
aussi mais il faut que ce soit quelque
chose de plus structuré je sais pas
comment expliquer quand ça devient un
peu humiliant où les gens se sont un peu
pas bien ou pas simple benji aussi senti
un peu offensé l'autre fois par rapport
à ses yeux en disant oui mais bon
maintenant j'ai un complexe est ce qu'il
a dit en rigolant ou pas premier second
degré je sais pas si on allait
pour moi c'est un peu blessant et je
deviens moi un peu de lucia sion s'est
alors je vais te réponds ça salit comme
c'est que nous on est tellement on
semble en fait qu'on se vannent
tellement dans les loges etc
on se donne tous ces mots si une vanne
tout ça mais n'ont qu'un temps
téléspectateurs on voit pas du tout 2 6
mais je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont que c'est une famille tu vois
c'est en fait on ne retire pas de la
brouille eric moi j'aimerais dire deux
choses à nos deux jeunes bon moi je fais
je suis pas un chroniqueur sur les
polémiques oui oui oui sur les
polémiques et sur êtes vous pour ou
contre cyril hanouna télévision moi je
suis pas un chroniqueur de métier j'ai
mon histoire je ne connaissais pas
l'univers de cyril hanouna je ne
connaissais pas cyril hanouna
il ya encore un et vous ne me connaissez
tous droits ce soir vous vois tu vas
voir on se connaît pas mais je vous vois
moi il ya deux choses que je met son
crédit et qui m'ont frappé c'est d'abord
le mouvement des gilet jaune savez il ya
beaucoup de sociologues beaucoup
d'universitaires qui réfléchissent aux
tendances laïques ont rien vu venir
cyril hanouna et je les dis et je le
redis devant lui j'ai dit à venir mais
ça ça m'a frappé c'est que c'est le
premier à avoir compris l'importance de
ce mouvement qui venait de la province
qui ne les territoires et qu'elle est
complètement secoué le pouvoir politique
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles à
mon avis aussi les ministres maintenant
viennent dans cette émission
puis la deuxième chose que vous
connaissez un peu la télé même si vous
n'êtes pas un conducteur professionnel
c'est alors moi je suis fascinée jeudi
soit par son énergie et par son
professionnalisme
ça c'est un truc que moi je mets à son
crédit si vous saviez ce que ça
représente comme com com com et fort
comme comme dynamisme de faire ce qu'il
fait moi je sais même pas comment il
fait beau temps de direct je veux dire
que vous verriez sans doute que
personnage différemment mais cyril a
raison on se connaît pas on n'est pas
forcément du même univers et bien même
si ben on aura peut-être le temps passe
mal à moi je voulais tirer ce coup de
chapeau parce que le mouvement des gilet
jaune
il aurait sans doute pas eu cet écho
dans la classe politique si cyril dans
cette émission dans btp l'année dernière
à peu près les mêmes potes ils en
avaient pas pris la mesure clément loïc
ou nikon lequel vaut réagir surtout ce
qu'on dit la fdj les jeunes c'est juste
pour faire le buzz
non et non je pense j'avais nous donne
autour de 5 et de les faire le buzz
non vous auriez dû venir là
le dirigeant d'accord mais juste toi
clément que je comprends ce qu'il dit
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui l'ont
dit et il a raison il représente voilà
des gens qui l'ont dit sur les réseaux
sociaux tout ça donc c'est bien qu'il le
dit c'est vrai qu'on après et son ami
s'est pas dit on va faire le buzz sur
les gilet jaune voilà après vous avez
invité les jeunes avant même la première
journée de mobilisation du 17 novembre
donc y avait pas encore ce buzz là il
ajuste flairé qui avait quelques pistes
et à reconnaître dans le pays sont venus
frapper à la région le soul élisant
domicile les ambulanciers plan de corps
de métiers venait devant on leur donne
leur parole parce qu'on leur donnait pas
la parole à leurs ailleurs les les
chaînes infos sont venus bien après et
voilà moi ce que je voulais juste
répondre à licorne
quand vous dites que certains certains
chroniqueurs se sentent offensés et
c'est moi j'ai partagé la table des
communications tpm paix pendant quelques
semaines je peux vous dire que en fait
moi c'est moi pourquoi je regarde pas
mon poste parce que c'est une émission
qui me ressemble n'y a pas beaucoup
d'émissions télévision qu'ils voient sur
la télévision ya clic chez beaucoup
d'amour sur sur canal mais et été pmp
moi avec mes potes
il ya un truc c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être parce qu'on a grandi comme ça
on aime se charrier on aime se vanner
entre nous moi ce que j'aime dans cette
émission c'est que je retrouve ça et je
peux vous dire que les chroniqueurs
l'année dernière pour avoir de bons
partageable la table avec eux ils sont
pas du tout au fond c'est au contraire
et je peux vous dire aussi que en loges
pour l'avoir vu ils gênent pas aussi
pour remettre des taquets et cyril ça
aussi série de l'assumer non voilà mais
c'est vrai que les téléspectateurs le
voit parfois fait ça et donc pour
revenir sur ce que disait jean et moi je
saigne encore quand j'entends ce truc de
mépris anna étant des bulles qui fait
une émission pour les débiles
dans la vie je bosse donc dans la
communication mais surtout pour des
politiques des politiques eux-mêmes et
des collaborateurs de politiques
regardent hanouna mais comme c'est pas
mainstream de lui dire comme il faut pas
que tout le monde sache qu'on regarde le
nom est bond préfère pas le nom préfère
ne pas le dire
les gens se soient rapidement ceux qui
font des grosses journées et qui aime
regarder annales swarm il n'y a pas que
il ya des sportifs des footballeurs avec
qui j'ai discuté des athlètes un athlète
qui m'a demandé vous passez bonjour
servira de ces rites qui va défendre nos
couleurs aux jo de tokyo et qui vous
apprécient ça s'est passé connaissez ray
lane où l'art non je ne connais
absolument pas bonjour alors alors et et
les et aussi les mères de famille moi
quand j'ai filmé quelques émissions et
sûreté pmp que je prenais le train le
matin gare du nord une maman qui est
venu me tapoté l'épaule
dites bonjour à si rudi kuyl je laime
juste ça c'était pas licorne et non ce
n'est pas du tout
et juste une dernière chose aussi parce
qu'on pense à eux ceux qui sont à
l'hôpital
ceux qui sont dans les prisons quoi
qu'ils aient fait il faut qu'ils aient
aussi qu'ils puissent vivre dans des
conditions dignes et se détendre aussi
le soir et moi pour finir je préfère
largement que mes enfants
matane d'accesoires sûreté pmp ou btp
plutôt qui matent certaines émissions de
télé-réalité ou autre ou là vraiment
c'est vulgaire et là où vraiment médias
du mais pour moi c'est une icône témoin
loïc je vais vous laisser un peu le mot
de la fin précis un dernier chroniqueurs
qui veut réagir mais alors licorne ont
sincèrement je trouve que téléréalité
tpm paix c'est exactement la même chose
à tout et réaliser mon avis ce sont des
jets droit de le dire bien sûr pour moi
c'est c'est du clash sans arrêt c'est
l'humiliation c'est juste déconné le
plus rigoler le plus à voir une bande de
potes en fait non parce que c'est un
gros impôts n'augmentent pas comme ça
dans gt mpc pour ça eric naulleau qui
ont des ânes ont lâché non mais moi j'ai
été dans votre position sert je
regardais étaient pipés je me posais des
questions si je me dis je suis content
que mes 24 poses licorne mais ils en
prennent plein la gueule est ce que bon
je suis à l'intérieur maintenant
franchement c'est ça marche dans les
deux sens mais même pendant l'émission
cheryl et l'on reçoit est vraiment c'est
une bande d'amis n'y a pas d'
humiliation il n'y a pas vraiment de de
tension d'animosité il n'y a pas
quelqu'un qui humilie et des humiliés
c'est vraiment une bande d'amis qui est
contente de se retrouver chaque soir une
enquête qui sont quand même le pauvre
mathieu qui s'en prend toujours plein la
gueule
on fera jamais rien
regardez les boutons et à 3,4 en afrique
on ne veut pas faire je vous assure
qu'on vous faut qu'on a forcé 2,3 on ne
nous force à le faire je vous assure que
c'est vrai et aussi vous l'avait dit et
votre présence en est la preuve
c'est un espace et hanouna le donne de
liberté d'exprimer et dix huit mois
l'année dernière j'étais pour cinq viols
ça qu'il me dise quoi que ce soit
d'ailleurs il m'a même demandé de me
calmer après en disant que j'avais un
petit peu trop tarder preuve que voilà
on peut dire ce qu'on veut
il m'a pas empêché de le faire avant il
m'a pas de riz fait avant qu'arrive
n'est pas faire agir si je peux me
permettre
sadou que la question chiffres peuvent
permettre et pas très bien posé êtes
vous pour ou contre thierry lannoy télé
franchement mecque et autant de buzz qui
fait qu'ils aient autant de succès on
peut pas se poser la question êtes vous
pour ou contre ate et a par contre
apprécié ou ou pas cyril hanouna là où
vous comprenez vous ce succès je
pourrais comprendre ce type de négation
mais on ne peut pas dire
etes-vous pour ou contre quelqu'un qui
fait un carton à la td et et chaque fois
qu'ils touchent une émission ça marche
donc c'est la question elle n'est pas à
mon avis bien posée pourquoi moi je me
retrouve dans la démarche de cyril
pareil que je connaissais pas quand
j'étais sur rmc et autres et puis si
raymond abouo un ami commun qui nous a
mis en relation des quais et ensuite
quand on s'est rencontré deux le courant
est passé très vite
il est passé très vite parce que il ya
une chose à laquelle je voulais répondre
en même temps licorne et sur laquelle
vous êtes posé la question est il le
même à l'écran grand dehors
oui la réponse est oui et moi c'est
toujours la question que les gens me
posent paru oui mais non mais en tant
qu'habitat trice moi je vois un certain
personnage très clown pente en déconneur
foufou 11e mais c'est pas possible
d'être comme elle est la réalité
moi je m'imagine marcher dans la rue
entendeur
je me retournerai la première je me dire
mais c'est qu'est ce vous si je vois
cyril en train de faire son souffle on
me disait comme beaucoup plus riche ce
jour je suis pire aux coulisses en jeu
des parisiens mais on me pose souvent la
question parce qu'ils ont envie de
savoir s'il joue un rôle ou pas et moi
je leur dis toujours il est à l'antenne
comme il est en dehors c'est le même il
joue pas et vous rendez compte le temps
qu'il faudrait pour jouer le rôle il est
à l'antenne un salarié ce qui peut pas
il peut pas être quelqu'un d'autre que
lui de qu'il est lui même et c'est pour
ça que ça marche donc un c'est qu'il est
un authentique
il est le même à l'antenne que dans la
vie 2 si quelqu'un de passionné et moi
dans la vie je préfère quand même côtoyé
des gens passionnés que des gens monrose
sinistre de queue et 3 c'est quelqu'un
qui est audacieux parce que moi ma
rencontre avec parle de balances ton
post alors qu'au départ on se voit parce
que au sun il me dit pourquoi tu ne te
dirai pas tpm p je lui dis moi je pense
que tu devrais faire une émission de
débat tu es un mec qui s'intéresse aux
débats de société fait une émission de
débat il me regarde un peu perplexe une
émission de débat oui fait une émission
de débat il ya besoin aujourd'hui que
tom public puisse aussi débattre de
sujets de société
tout de suite il a percuté deux heures
après il me dit c'est bon mal à faire
est génial ça n'existe pas ça legarda à
vraie vie les gens oui on va voir on va
faire une réunion puis rang et puis en
bas je vous en parle et puis je vous
envoie un email puis pragmatique
audacieux il sent les coups un moment
donné et ça c'est effectivement ça
génère de jalousie parce que dans la vie
on peut pas faire l'unanimité surtout 90
personnalités une personnalité est
toujours clivante
moi je comprends que des gens qui
l'aiment pas je comprends que des gens
qui me passent une personnalité autre à
un moment donné il ya une balance à la
vie est-ce que vous avez 4 avec du
caractère comme il a 37 audacieux comme
la cause est authentique et passionnés
comme idée est ce que bon vous avez des
gens qui sont en faveur des jeunes sont
contre vous aurez toujours un peu des
deux mais la réalité c'est qu'il a
énormément de gens qui l'apprécient et
le dernier point mais non c'est le
dernier qui permet moi qui fais un peu
des médias franchement regardez la
diversité du public
moi je suis désolé de dire je défends
autant que je puisse le faire
une société française unis alors qu'elle
est fragmenté et de plus en plus
renvoyer chacun a ses origines à sa
religion à son sexe à son quartier
quand vous regardez publique syrienne a
je pense qu'on n'a pas beaucoup comme ça
et il est beau surtout il est mixte
le fait que vous l'applaudissent et que
vous leur confiez blick
mais c'est important quand vous avez une
des bases sur les femmes voilées que
nous sommes les seuls qui donne la
parole aux femmes voilées
après tout le monde n'a pris le train en
marche quand amélie gilet jaune et que
le public il ya un maximum de gilet
jaune qui avaient le sentiment qu'ils
étaient pas pires que ceux des roms
quand vous avez des gens qui font la
grève est en face de nous tous iront
plainte d'une profession mettez
m'initier si vous n'appréciez pas cette
démarche là si elle apprécie quand
j'apprécie c'est simplement cyril un
serment oui mais te demander tu dis
toujours je fais attention à tout ce que
vous racontez moi je lis votre genre on
sait que je regardais je regarde je vais
lui plante tweet à toi d'ailleurs c'est
très bien ce que j'en ai écrit
énormément je sais où aller
et puis si on verra tout le monde tout
le monde peut les lire moi je n'ai pas
fermé mais sincèrement quand tu lis tous
tous les gens qui écrivent des choses
sur toi pas des insultes gratuites mais
des choses vraiment qui prend au fond de
bruit tout alors qu'ils expliquent le
pourquoi jean la banque alimentaire où
elle si elle en est pourquoi elle n'est
toujours pas pourquoi j'étais du
chocolat qu'elle a des gens qui me
regardent pas du chocolat non mais c'est
de l'eau avec les téléspectateurs
on voit que du chocolat qui parlait
partout et on comprend pas que voilà un
grand pas pour la banque du meilleur
mais chérie ça va arriver là dès 2020 ce
qu'on a mis beaucoup de temps à mettre
en place c'est un énorme projet pour
aider énormément de gens donc c'est vrai
qu'on a mis en place voilà les choses et
ça va arriver en 2020 j'en ai parlé mais
j'avais dit qu'on aime en 2020 parce que
ça va 100 ça va on va le lancer en mars
je vois ce 2020 c'est sûr voilà à la fin
à jeanne divers maximum mars ba oui mais
bon on est obligé de mineurs et
association mais là tu sais très bien
que tu me reproches que l'on sait des
choses mais je suis obligé de prendre le
temps parce que sinon patient fait avait
annoncé précédemment que c'était pour
cet hiver je sais mais on a mal jury
administrativement j'ai beaucoup
travaillé comme s'impliquer dans six
mois je préfère avoir des explications
miceli salle est la bonne et licorne a
raison parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
très bonne qu est la vie
layton je préfère que ce soit bien bien
ficelé et qu'on est tous bien vraiment
abordés mais c'est facile on lance le
truc et que c'est un fiasco derrière je
vais m'en vouloir on va pouvoir pas
pouvoir aider tous les gens qui en ont
besoin et ça va être un problème donc on
va le lancer
ça sera fini en mars c'est sûr et ce
sera lancée en mars
quoi qu'il arrive et lens en janvier
salle est en mars et c'est sûr et
certain et on en train de travailler
tous les jours dessus avec les équipes
série d'une dernière bernard laporte
beaucoup de choses ont été dites avec
damon pour ces choses là on va passer au
régionalisme et générosité moi je
résumerais pour comparer un petit peu au
monde du sport c'est quoi la différence
entre un grand entraîneur et un moment
c'est pas la tennis est pas la tactique
c'est la qualité humaine qui fait la
différence c'est la proximité avec ses
joueurs tirés la quête des seins de ses
joueurs déchire il sait ce qu'il apporte
que son chroniqueur fait on est à l'aise
on est bien ici mais j'ai pas que c'est
une histoire vous n'êtes pas de pression
mais quelle impression vous pas
l'impression avec l'entraîneur comme ça
c'est à dire dit il comme est-il de mai
à l'aise c'est évident et je crois et
ses succès qui fait que effectivement
tout le monde est jaloux au péché tout
le monde est jaloux de les marins on
n'est pas jaloux de müller vous ne sais
pas qui c'est photo ap voilà donc on
n'est jamais chez moi mais c'est ce que
je lui dit comprendre jour le jour
[Applaudissements]
mais comme tout vrai rebond derradji oui
on dit toujours tu n'aimes pas c'est
parce que tu es jalouse non toi tu es
passé ça m'aidera dans le métier tout ça
donc moi je suis jean côté artistique je
dis haut et fort je fais pas partie si
je gêne énormément de personnes qui sont
socialement isolées
je fais beaucoup de bien pour l'heure
personne qu'elles repartent avec le
sourire je je je travaille en fait tout
ce qui est artistique de ce côté là pour
qu'elle puisse s'épanouir ces
personnes-là de reprendre confiance - la
dent mais bon je suis dans le domaine
dans le milieu dont le capa d'ingérer a
bien du mal à aucun mot j'ai aucune
ressenti de téléspectatrices de tout
l'aspect très triste et comme je le lui
ai bien marqué dans ma bio je suis dans
l'empathie pour l'empathie par rapport
aux gens qui ont le mérite mais quand je
vois comme gilles et les buzzer les
[ __ ] a cliqué tout ça sincèrement ça
touche pas ça me touche absolument pas
et il n'y a aucune jalousie l'adénome
quoi aller très vite on va juste pour
terminer dit quand vous êtes en train de
résumer avec tout ce que veut nous dire
qu'en réalité vous êtes pro hanouna
puisque vous est vrai pour ceux qui sont
dans le besoin
hanouna elle le fait avec les régalades
avec ce qu'on voit pas aussi à l'antenne
et dont je peux attester
avec ce qu'il fait avec la banque du
coeur qui en fait ce que vous faites
aussi s'est créé un grand élan de
générosité
passée une chaîne de l'espoir et de la
solidarité et une dernière chose parce
qu'on en a pas parlé
karim a raison il ya annales audacieux
et c'est là qu'a créé une émission pour
amener des jeunes vers la politique
il ya aussi hanouna qui a fait un truc
que personne d'autre n'a fait dans les
médias depuis des années ramenée de la
diversité ramener des gens dans le
public a dans des bonnes conditions pour
les gens en situation de handicap même
mieux avec des pmp ouvert à tous les
mettre autour de la table pour leur
donner la parole et je trouve ça
incroyable
[Applaudissements]
eric naulleau est ce que vous allez
continuer l'émission sont moins bons
c'est normal c'est notre public 1,61 on
a quand même 24 % compte
vous avez bien fait 24 % donc ramassé
énorme merci et je le même déjà qui
regardent l'émission je le dis à licorne
et il ya beaucoup beaucoup de critiques
qui sont très constructives dans ce que
je lis sur les réseaux sociaux
et il m'est arrivé de lire des tweets à
toi et de me dire c'est vrai qu'elle a
raison mais je te le dis moi je suis
extrêmement naturelle dans l'émission et
c'est vrai qu'en fait tu vois je suis
voilà j'ai du mal à changer
voilà donc j'ai essayé de faire des
efforts pour toi parce que je sais que
tu représentes pas mal de gens
représentent des gens je représente les
dix jeux représentent représente alim
représentants veut regarder quand même
l'émission parce que je les adores et là
c'est ça et c'est pour ça moi
aujourd'hui je ne la regarde pas ce que
je ne supporte plus j'ai pas de dieu de
honte j'ai apprécié les nord tu fais au
niveau de btp cette création comme je
disais pour dechavanne mais après tout
la côte et en faire un peu moins les
meilleures blagues sont les plus courtes
alors il y aura peut-être une dernière
fois du chocolat jeu sera pas ce sera
courant et j'espère bien merci merci
d'avoir été là message alors vas-y dis
moi tu es une saveurs d'orient
en fait j'ai perdu mon alternance en bts
mc au le 24 novembre et du coup je
recherche une autre et donc ça pour
passer un message que sur paris ça veut
dire c'est un management commercial à
bellegem
sauf que la chaîne de solidarité permet
de 2,93
loïc donc voilà en seine saint denis et
bah écoutez si voilà loïc cherche voilà
bastien d'oeil sur les réseaux sociaux
ouais merci ben voilà mais merci loïc
bon voilà bah très bien loïc il ya
quelqu'un qui vend un truc sur le bon
coin
[Applaudissements]